so there's two other topics that aren't
mine but i still love them
one of them let's just talk about it
briefly because it's not a probe but
it's the idea to send a telescope very
far away to 500 times the earth sun
distance
and this is way farther than the voyager
spacecrafts are right now
and to use our sun as a gravitational
lens
to use our sun to magnify something
that's behind it
it's got to sink in for a minute yeah
exactly but i mean
i don't know what the physics of that is
like how to use the sun in astronomy and
einstein thought about this initially
we can use uh massive objects bend space
yeah
and so light that should be traveling
like straight it actually
travels around the warped space and
somehow
you figure out a way to use that for
magnification
you have a way to use that for
magnification that's right
there are galaxies uh that are lens
so-called gravitational lens by
intervening galaxy
clusters actually and there are
microlensing events where stars get
magnified
as an unseen gravitational lens star
passes in between us and that very
distant star
it's actually a real tool in astronomy
yeah using gravitational lensing
to magnify because it bends more rays
towards you than normally would
you normally see and again we're trying
to get more
higher resolution images
that are basically boiled down to light
well it boils down to light
and then you can maybe get more
information about
well in this case you would ask me let's
say
if this thing could get built it would
take
like something like they'd like to say
25 years to get from here to there
25 years and then it could send some
information back to us and then you'd
say so sarah how many pixels
and i wouldn't say one or less than one
i'd say you know it could be like 10 by
10 pixels
it could be 100 pixels which would be
awesome i mean it's still crazy that we
can get a lot of information from that
crazy right and it's crazy for a lot of
other reasons because again you have to
line up the sun and your target
you'd only have one telescope per target
because every star
is behind the sun in a different way
you